[Aplausos]
perteneció a un arma 38 especial
este resorte que podría ser de cualquier
cosa
perteneció
a una ak-47
se han fabricado
más de 100 millones de ak-47 en el mundo
y esa quizás sea la razón por la cual
cada rato en los medios la vemos como
protagonista de los principales hechos
delictivos
no sabemos a ciencia cierta cuántas
personas fueron lastimadas
o incluso asesinadas con estas armas
pero hoy con certeza si les puedo decir
que estas armas nunca más van a lastimar
a nadie
hace nueve años empecé a proponer
destruir armas de fuego para
convertirlas en obras de arte es decir
tomar objetos que fueron diseñados para
lastimar y para matar y convertirlos en
obras con mensajes positivos
toda esta transformación física me lleva
a venir a proponerles hoy toda una
transformación de personas de sociedades
y del mundo yo nací acá en san josé de
costa rica inmediatamente me llevaron
para la abuela la segunda provincia del
país y ahí crecí en un ambiente idóneo
como creo que todos los niños deben
crecer en un ambiente y un entorno
pacífico con motivación
con padres que me enseñaron valores con
el ejemplo
en mi época escolar
duraba cerca de 20 o 30 minutos haciendo
la tarea de la escuela
y me tardaba alrededor de tres horas o
más haciendo el dibujo que iba a
acompañar esa tarea
estudié en un colegio privado católico
donde también reforzaron mis valores
cuándo
entré a la universidad y me enfrenté a
la disyuntiva de que querer estudiar el
arte no estaba entre dentro de mis
opciones tenía que estudiar algo que
fuera rentable económicamente hablando
cuando empecé a trabajar realmente nunca
me adapté mucho a trabajar para otras
personas siempre tenía
un sentimiento emprendedor
y eso me hizo crear
una de las primeras empresas de diseño
web en costa rica
en esos años no era fácil vender una
página web ni siquiera se vislumbraba el
boom tecnológico que ahora tenemos aún
así y con mucho esfuerzo logré sacar
adelante esta empresa logré tener éxito
sintiéndome en la cima del mundo
aún así sentía grandes vacíos no me
sentía del todo gusto a gusto conmigo
mismo
empiezo a tomar malas decisiones en mi
vida profesional y en mi vida personal
incluso en un momento llegué a pensar en
comprar un artefacto de estos
y atentar contra la vida de una persona
e inclusive contra mi propia vida
por los valores con los que fui creados
creo que no cometí un error de estos y
más bien logré revertir esta situación
logré hacer grandes introspección es
y al analizar me a mí mismo me encontré
con aquel niño que dibujaba y que soñaba
con hacer arte
en ese momento
decidí cambiar mi saco y mi corbata y
dedicarme al arte
me fina temporada para la playa
y ahí fue como una explosión pintaba
alrededor de 16 o 18 horas al día ahí
comprendí que eso era lo que yo había
venido a hacer a esta dimensión
pero no venía a ser un arte solamente
para decorar espacios venía a ser un
arte que generara mensaje que generará
conciencia que generará cambios hice en
ese momento una colección que se llamó
puertas del mundo en alusión a que
tenemos que abrir puertas cerrar puertas
en un proceso de evolución en un proceso
de cambio
un tiempo después un hecho maravilloso
se dio en mi vida nació mi hija maría
fernanda yo antes de que ella naciera
decía que este mundo iba directo a la
autodestrucción
y yo decía bueno si somos tan
inconscientes pues que se destruya
cuando ella nació yo dije
qué va yo tengo que hacer algo para
dejarle un mejor planeta a ella y en
ella veo reflejados a los niños del
planeta y a las futuras generaciones y
ha sido mi mayor inspiración para toda
esta causa que vengo gestando
un año más o menos después de que ella
naciera es decir hace unos nueve años
empiezo a ver soy reunido con un amigo
en una banca en la universidad para la
paz y allí me enteraron por primera vez
que en costa rica se destruían armas de
fuego pensábamos en una escultura
y ahí se dieron los dos primeros
ingredientes para lo que luego vendría
un tiempito después un hecho muy
lamentable sucede en el país
un joven
muchacho toma el arma que su padre
compró para autodefensa y protección y
termina asesinando a la directora de su
colegio
eso me dio los ingredientes que me
faltaban para para la receta
entrega voluntaria de armas de fuego
donde la gente también pudiera
participar y toda una campaña de
generación de conciencia sobre la
violencia y la inseguridad
de esta forma nace una idea hacer arte
con trozo de armas me reúno con los
personeros del ministerio de seguridad
y con el apoyo de la dirección general
de armamento medo eran los primeros 15
kilos de trozos de armas con estos hago
la primera obra pictórica que hasta
donde sabemos se ha hecho en el mundo
una obra pictórica es una pintura sí
habían hecho esculturas es decir habían
tomado piezas de estas y habían hecho
ensambles pero nunca habían hecho una
pintura yo en cluster estas partes en la
madera y luego pinte en ellas usando las
armas o los trozos de las armas como
textura con esta obra estuve en una
bienal en una exposición muy importante
en el museo de arte contemporáneo de
cuzco en perú
regresando a costa rica
y con el apoyo del entonces el ministro
de seguridad
me donan cerca de 400 kilos de trozos de
armas y con ellos hago la colección
transformación en tiempos violentos una
colección compuesta por 21 obras 21
obras todas inspiradas en valores
humanos como la paz la tolerancia el
respeto la solidaridad la lealtad la
espiritualidad
y esto porque creo que los valores es
importante retomar los en un mundo como
el que vivimos esa esas son las bases
para la construcción de una nueva
humanidad basada en una verdadera
cultura de paz
estas obras las hemos exhibido en más de
30 exposiciones y eventos en todo el
país en los principales museos museos
que antes eran cuarteles militares y
ahora son casas de cultura
estamos planeando todo una gira mundial
con estas obras llevando un mensaje de
paz y de transformación de costa rica
para el mundo
pero más que una transformación de
objetos físicos
que como les decía antes
objetos diseñados para lastimar y matar
transformados en obras con mensajes
positivos más que eso esto también
implica una transformación de personas y
de sociedades hace aproximadamente 5
años empecé a trabajar en la reforma el
centro penitenciario más grande y quizás
problemático del país
ahí empecé con un grupo de unas 20
personas con un taller de pintura y eso
se ha convertido en todo un programa y
con la ayuda de muchos voluntarios ahora
damos talleres de fotografía de
literatura de poesía de música de teatro
ay he conocido personas talentosas que
si hubieran tenido otras oportunidad no
estarían en una casa
personas que han tenido 25 años desde
muy chicos brincando de un centro a otro
y ahora me dicen profe yo quiero ser
parte la fundación dar charlas y hacer
que personas jóvenes no cometan los
mismos errores ahí trabajamos en
restauración y reinserción social pero
también trabajamos con niños con jóvenes
en las comunidades de riesgo en
comunidades como la carpio en el oeste
del país una comunidad urbano marginal
donde motivamos a estos chicos para que
no lleguen a las drogas para que no
lleguen a las pandillas y para que no
llegue a una cárcel
todo esto nos indica que el camino a
seguir no es más represión no es poner
más policías no es hacer más cárceles el
camino es invertir en la gente en
educación en cultura en arte
el mundo gasta cerca de 6 mil millones
de dólares anuales y 6 mil billones con
b
esos son muchísimos ceros ahí está el
dinero que necesitamos para la
construcción de un nuevo planeta
pero cómo revertir esto cómo decirle a
los señores que fabrican estas armas que
dejen de hacerlo
en tiempos de la segunda guerra mundial
ante la amenaza nazi alguien dijo deja
lo que estés haciendo y las armas para
la guerra
yo les digo hoy
dejen de fabricar armas y fabriquen
cosas positivas para construir un mejor
mañana
y si eso no es suficiente estamos
planteando y vamos pronto a hacer todo
un movimiento artístico revolucionario
no violento donde vamos a destruir
tanques de guerra helicópteros militares
y cuánto artefacto el ico podamos en los
parques de las principales ciudades del
mundo
en sus murales nos vamos a hacer con
artistas de todos los países y los vamos
a inaugurar con los músicos más
importantes del mundo y vamos a tomar
las ciudades también invitando a los
actores a la gente de danza a todas las
artes
de hecho ya empezamos acabamos de hacer
un mural en el colegio de periodistas
donde usamos cerca de 200 kilos de
trozos de armas en un mural
que habla de la libertad de prensa
y de la paz
quizás ustedes que hoy me escuchan
piense en este artista se volvió loco
pues déjenme decirles que ya soy un poco
familiarizado con ese concepto porque
cuando decidí quitarme el saco
y empezar a hacer arte muchos pensaron
que me ha vuelto loco cuando decidí
empezar a hacer arte con armas
de igual forma ni hablar cuando entré a
las comunidades de riesgo y a las
cárceles
otra vez me dijeron que estaba loco
ahora que espero
cambiar y usar el arte como un
instrumento poderoso de transformación
probablemente piensen que soy loco
pero déjenme decirles que si que si
estoy loco pero estoy loco por ver un
mejor planeta por ver un mundo que
cambie por ere darle a mi hija y a las
futuras generaciones un mejor mundo y
ahí los instó a todos a que también sean
parte de esta gran transformación
la paz es responsabilidad de todos
y ahí tenemos todos que dejar salir a
esos niños que todos llevamos dentro a
creer que todo es posible
y ahí juntos podremos construir un mejor
mañana y un mejor futuro muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]